what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have some really awesome covers
of empire magazine one is a great shot
of just doctor strange but the other is
complete madness and there is so much to
break down in it and it looks like we
actually have some pretty hard evidence
that the scarlet witch is truly the
villain of multiverse of madness and i'm
going to show this by linking some
things in this poster to some things
that we've actually seen and i spotted
in the trailers for multiverse of
madness the main one and the teaser
trailer so let's break this down and of
course if you love marvel news be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos so the first cover of
empire magazine that we'll check out
today for multiverse of madness is the
one that is just doctor strange this one
is really awesome but it's pretty
straightforward it's of doctor strange
he's doing some magic not a ton to
digest here but there is a few things to
talk about one is a good look at the eye
of agamotto now we've seen this in the
trailers and a lot of people have been
wondering well didn't thanos crush the
eye of agamotto with his hand and the
answer is yes he did but as he said when
he crushed it it was a fake and a lot of
us obviously assumed that he was
referring to the time stone but perhaps
he was referring to the eye of agamotto
as well i doubt such a powerful mystical
item could be destroyed so easily and
even if it was i'm pretty sure doctor
strange could mend it because as we can
see it doesn't actually contain the time
stone it's just the eye of agamotto
strange 100 does not have the time stone
back but keep in mind in the comics the
eye of agamotto actually didn't hold the
time stone it simply had an eye in it
now the origins of the eye were unknown
the eye of agamotto was created by
agamotto and some believe that the eye
in it could actually be the eye of
agamotto agamotto was earth's very first
sorceress supreme he's a very powerful
mystical being and one of dr strange's
three vishanti so the actual eye of
agamotto could contain power on its own
and that is perhaps why doctor strange
is still wearing it even though it
doesn't have the time stone now
something really cool about this cover
is what it says on the bottom it says
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and then it says benedict
cumberbatch powers up for the mcu's
terrifying thrill ride it seems like
they are still kind of sticking true to
what this film was originally supposed
to be the mcu's first horror type film
now obviously not a full-on horror film
after all it is still pg-13 and was
never going to be rated r but it is
going to be dark and we've definitely
seen that from the trailers i am
expecting a lot of deaths in this movie
even if it is people from other
different universes now moving on to the
next poster which could be one of the
best marvel posters that we've seen this
poster truly is madness very fitting for
the movie there are just a ton of
portals in this cover and of course the
focus is still on doctor strange and the
scarlet witch now i actually think that
this poster is somewhat misleading there
is a lot happening in this poster but
one thing that you see a lot of is the
tentacles of gargantos gargantos is the
being with the huge eye that we see in
the trailer with all the tentacles and
it looks like we are made to believe
that this is probably going to be one of
the main villains and you can spot many
of gargantos tentacles on this poster
however i think this is a misdirect i
think the scarlet witch truly is going
to be the main villain of this film now
they kind of allude at that a little bit
in multiverse of madness trailers but
really we're kind of led to believe that
doctor strange is the main villain along
with some other villains like argantos
but here's a few things that i noticed
about this cover and this cover is by
chris malbon one is rintrow some people
don't know who this is he's in the
portal in the top left ringtrot is an
apprentice of doctor strange in the
comics and we actually just saw him in
the official trailer for multiverse of
madness it does appear like he is a
sorcerer and will be joining the battle
against who i believe is the scarlet
witch and here is a sign of that below
him is wang and he looks pretty beat up
and i think this is from a very specific
scene in the trailer specifically where
the scarlet witch is attacking the
comrades now the reason that i believe
that it is the scarlet witch is because
we have all of the masters of the mystic
arts and all of their trainees looking
up into the sky and in one scene we also
see doctor strange there looking up into
the sky as well so it's not doctor
strange they're looking at and we know
that the carmitage gets attacked so it's
not him attacking we can only assume
it's wanda at this point the scarlet
witch and here's why in a scene from the
very first teaser trailer we can see
that wang is actually being bound and if
you take a close enough look you can see
that his hands are bound by red magic
now of course who uses red magic chaos
magic wanda the scarlet witch so she is
the one that actually has wong bound up
here which leads me to believe that she
is indeed the one that is attacking the
carmitage also to further prove that it
is not doctor strange attacking the
karma taj we actually have a tv spot
where it shows doctor strange floating
up in the sky facing away from everybody
and we can see actually below him the
archers are pointing nowhere near him he
is right above them they are pointing at
an incoming threat so i really do think
the scarlet witch is the main villain of
this movie now back to the poster if we
look below we can see mordo with a
crossbow now there's actually been some
rumors of this that somebody called
prime morta would have a crossbow in the
movie now who is prime morta well we're
not actually sure prime mordo could be
the mortal from our universe or he could
be someone from something called the
prime universe now prime means main most
important so i would like to say that
he's from our universe however the
mortar that we see in all of these
trailers i actually believe is going to
be from a different universe so we'll
have to wait and see on that now to his
left we can actually see defender
strange which is rather interesting i
actually assumed and i think a lot of
people did as well that defender strange
was going to die very early on in the
movie i actually assumed that he was the
doctor strange from the universe where
america chavez comes from and he
sacrifices himself in order to save her
and send her to our universe in the very
first teaser trailer it kind of does
seem like he dies but if they put him on
a poster he either does something
extremely important or he's in the movie
kind of frequently so i find it
interesting that he's on here so perhaps
maybe he doesn't die now at the bottom
there's a picture of just a giant eye
and i'm assuming that this is just
gargantos but when we see gargantos in
the trailer his eye is actually red and
in some parts of the trailer it's blue
and in this poster it's actually yellow
now this could just be the design of the
poster it could mean nothing or it could
be somebody else i'm assuming that this
movie is going to have several twists
and several cameos that we did not
expect to show up so there is always the
possibility that it is somebody else but
it really does look like the eye of
gargantos now to the right we have
america chavez and we know that she
comes from a different universe and we
actually kind of know that gargantos
comes from that universe as well it's
hunting her down and this is where our
doctor strange and r wong meet america
chavez when they help defend her they
help rescue her from this gargantus then
if we look to the top right we can
actually see a tyrannosaurus rex now
some people on twitter have been a
little bit confused about this why
there's a dinosaur there we actually see
dinosaurs in the official trailer and
what universe this is well it could be
the main universe but it's a place
called the savage land it's from marvel
comics and there are dinosaurs there and
what's really interesting about this is
it has a huge connection to the x-men
and we already know that professor x is
going to be in the movie and that would
make an x-men in the film so big
connections there and then of course in
the middle we have doctor strange and
the scarlet witch who of course are the
two main characters of the film and the
hero and villain it appears to be but
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below is the scarlet
witch the true villain of the movie or
is it her variant that is the villain or
perhaps they are both the villains let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest marvel
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you